[Music]
sponsored by WB games welcome back to
inside Lego dimensions I'm Chris and I'm
Aaron from game grumps y'all we are
talking about the Simpsons today now The
Simpsons are in the starter pack but
there's also a Simpsons level pack
that's what we're delving into oh my
goodness oh yeah pull him out get him
out here
oh yeah Hobart
I'm a merchant in he's got those Cola
where my boy your Homer voice is so
questionable due to their shirt put him
on the pad let's get into it put him on
the pad boom there goes oh he just jumps
out
are you Moammar alright get up here
we're gonna go into the Simpsons level
every level pack comes with a story
level but you can select right from the
start as soon as you plump the character
down oh really yeah
it's the mysterious voyage of Homer here
we go Homer and Gandalf now have
together again for the first time yeah
we need to get ourselves to the great
chili cook-off and what better way to do
that than by smashing some stuff with
over 20 candle has bowel problems so
well Homer has some intestinal issues of
his own slugging that buzz Cola in the
pod belching solo oh my god smashes the
dude
yeah that's calling this gonna belch on
Gandalf a little bit don't oh god you're
disrupting me disrupting light with my
mad
we need more parts all right we gotta
get up on the roof here Gandalf how are
you at climbing ladders not super great
I'm a super-duper old guy all right
Homer is on the case I'll do it hey I
see I'll call you oh no it's the the
three-eyed bird from the power plant boy
Homer work the jack what is he trying to
do trying to open the garage door is
that what you doing yeah he's just
really clumsy oh nice you know are you
guys because what's parked inside Homer
oh yeah Homer Moby oh all right let's
get this car into action oh here it
comes
whoa Gandalf I'm gonna take this one
buddy like how many gets in its living
costs
watch out Edna what sort of wait don't
forget about Gandalf
oh yeah see you later yeah a good friend
Gandalf I guess I'll just walk through
the nuclear sewage oh I can you go I
shall not pass
all right Gandalf I'll see you later ah
let's just y-you just take a little
timeout Gandalf this is the Homer show
good Oh Homer using there's a house full
of horrible belching for good all right
Gandalf if you want to hop back in now
you can you throw it no that's some
Batman stuff right there it's if it's
one grapple hook area then it's Batman
but if it's three then it's a vehicle Oh
like mine ripping this thing apart you
may notice that there is still a large
truck in the way yes mmm
that makes Homer mud whoa oh yeah he's
angry what the heck how did you do that
that's homers powers that get angry he
gets super big whoa okay ba-ba-ba-ba-bom
gonna be wizard head now there are parts
here we've got some of these shining
silver objects now we may have glimpsed
these in the starter pack episode but
Homer has its own unique solution for
how to deal with this really well yes
Aaron and as you know TV is a very
destructive force in our culture and so
here we have a TV that is literally used
for destruction this is the thing that
overcomes it it's you know you sit down
here you watch Itchy and Scratchy
you pick up the TV you can move it
around but what is the TV if not it's
not a giant bomb
you pop it off the pad and a ticks town
and blows up a whoa so that you can
build the next thing that's really cool
you can see how that would come in handy
oh wow that's really cool I like how
it's like it's like a function of it to
take it off yeah you put it on you pull
it off all right Gandalf can you hop in
here I need some smashes yeah I'll smash
some stuff up for you I mean so we're at
the chili contest and you see there Ned
Flanders mr. burns are waiting for
homework to sample their children
however there's a problem
Ned but his like literally set his whole
operation on fire
Oh No yeah yeah maybe bit off more than
he can chew
firehouse Ned's five-alarm chili yeah oh
I can use my magic powers to raise these
things together
Gandalf definitely calls them magic I
like the donut reticle and like you know
Gandalf has his like special like when
you're aiming holding down square he's
got his specials like elvish reticle oh
yeah yeah oh yeah look at that it's kind
of magic you all right Homer taste that
chili is it good don't like chili not
taste good
his eyes are very free it gives me that
the bad news it's maybe one too alarm
with breasts oh dang well now it's time
for that salt Peter Kelly
so here's another tip if you pick up the
car if you want the car to come close to
you you can use the hold triangle and
use this menu or just lift up lift it up
off the toy pad put it back down and lo
and behold
is your sweet bride once we ride whoo
it's whoa dang sweet ride is perfect for
recklessly charging through on fire
barrels of fire but really does seem
like a bad idea to be driving this
through a little festival it's the Homer
Simpson way oh the rats all right well
you know what
rat poison just seems a little crass so
let's just lure these rats away using
every rats favorite show AGN Scratchy
where did that TV go they're itchy
they're scratchy they're itchy and
scratchy here it is
I found you take it over and let him
watch look at that look I'm flock you
watch TV oh here we go the super heart
watermelon something deluxe magma pepper
only get a little cocky yeah unlike a
creamy trip that's right got some
strange stomach vibes off those peppers
and it's off into a surreal Wonderland
so this is where the story level
continues in the Simpsons level pack but
we're gonna hop over to the adventure
level and take a look at Springfield but
on the way we're gonna learn a little
something about vehicles so back here in
Wharton you hop on the toy pad and you
can access a bunch of stuff from the
menu really easily we've hopped into
levels this way but this is also where
you're gonna upgrade the vehicle or item
that your character has so homers got
the car
he's got the Tonto vision mmm we're
gonna look at the car okay we want to
soup this baby up so let's make it and
you're spending all the gems that you
bought so you got more powerful yeah
give me double speed boost whoa let me
get some more power give the ability to
fire dang so now we're really talking
upgrades I mean this thing has
projectiles tow bars complete instantly
get some minds look at this mines
explosive stuff 5x oh yeah
all right do you have 5x more lines at a
time and you can even change the
appearance so now we've got wood
paneling
Wow yeah look at that and they
nice an orange we're just one upgrade
away we're gonna upgrade to jump ability
now our car can jump shoot lay mines
whoa we can jump oh yeah and we can
spend some gold bricks and a whole bunch
of studs to unlock the version that
sails on water here we're giving you
guys a sneak peek at what it looks like
to build both the Tonto vision and the
car in their second forms of course all
level packs at 3 flex so here we are in
the Homer craft and we've taken it to
another adventure world there's a
Simpsons one of course with a level pack
but this is the Lord of the Rings
Gandalf my buddy brought me here that's
right because this is where the Homer
crafts excels on water sits around oh
man look at me cruising man the lagoon
what is this strange thing out here whoa
oh there's something oh yeah I believe
this is a pad whoa whoa helps watch you
back up top in case you get turned
around awesome
so the Homer craft is great on water and
that's one of the fun things about
upgrading your vehicle is getting to use
it in different situations it actually
is like you saw hopping around on land
yeah if I want to use a you know the
homework are on land I should just stick
with the normal car but if I'm taking a
joyride out in the Anduin River then the
hover the Homer craft is what I want the
Anduin river yeah man that's some Lord
of the Rings knowledge right there mmm
you got the Lord of the Rings knowledge
I got to go back to the future knowledge
we're a dynamic duo
that's right so I'm gonna punch this be
we're so dynamic we split our screen Wow
actually that kind of space plans in
that B so here we have some hobbits this
is the glimpse of the Lord of the Rings
adventure world if we get up to a little
elevated place here we can see you've
got Minas Tirith in the distance even
further up the hill a glimpse of the bow
rod or
home of the Dark Lord Sauron really and
another year Lord of the Rings oh yeah
bro
Rivendell right up their house of Elrond
and the elves
so in these adventure worlds there are
like lots of places to visit and of
course each place collectibles
characters the whole shenanigans so even
though Homer has his own story level and
adventure world to come with The
Simpsons level pack and and the story
level that's in the starter pack there's
just something special about going and
visiting someone else the world Homer
Simpson and Lord of the Rings in the
Batmobile yes please
[Music]
you